♪ ♪
>> Greg: THE MEDIA’S FAVORITE
WAY TO REPORT A STORY FROM A
PRISM OF TWO IDEAS WHERE THEY
ARE LIFERS.
THE TWO IDEAS YOU ARE EITHER
PRO-IMMIGRATION OR A ZENO PHONE
THE BIGOT AND YOU LOVE THE BIG
OIL OR FOR PEACE WHERE YOU
WANT WAR.
THE LATEST, YOU SHUT DOWN THE
ECONOMY AND DEFINITELY OR YOU
WANT PEOPLE TO DIE.
THAT PREPOSTEROUS FILTER MAKES
IT EASY FOR THEM TO SLAM THE
OTHER SIDE AND ABSOLVES THEM OF
NUANCE, INTELLIGENCE, AND THROW
UP A LIST WHICH ARE COMPLETELY
MISSING HERE.
>> HE IS A FAN OF MONEY FIRST,
MORTALITY SECOND, THE GREATEST
GENERATION, THEY WILL BE
SACRIFICED FOR WHAT?
FEAR THAT TRUMP’S EFFORTS BE
PRESIDENT WILL BE HEARD?
>> HE IS GOING TOO FAST, CAUSING
CONFUSION AND QUITE POSSIBLY
ENDANGERING LIVES IN THE PROCESS
PERIODS >> STAYING IN AND FOR
THE PRESIDENT TO MAKE LIGHT OF T
SO WHAT, SOME PEOPLE WILL DIE,
BUT THE ECONOMY WILL GROW, NO.
>> THE PRESIDENT IS EAGER TO GET
THE ECONOMY BACK ON TRACK
BECAUSE HE SEE TO HIS CHANCES OF
BEING REELECTED TO.
>> THE PRESIDENT IS PUTTING
HUMAN LIFE AT RISK.
IT IS LITERALLY IMMORAL.
>> Greg: LITERALLY.
WHO IS SHE?
DO THEY BELIEVE TRUMP IS PUTTING
THE ECONOMY BEFORE HUMAN LIFE?
NO, IT IS AGAIN THESE IDIOTS
PLAYED TO KEEP BUSY.
THE EFFECTIVE SOLUTIONS TO
PROBLEMS AREN’T EITHER/OR BUT
THIS AND THAT AND WE WILL BE
FLEXIBLE AND EVER CHANGING
DEPENDING ON THE RISK AS WE
IDENTIFY THEM.
SO IT MAY BE THAT WE RETURN TO
WORKING PHASES, YOUNG AND
HEALTHY FIRST, DEPENDING ON
REGION AND TYPE OF BUSINESS.
THERE ARE LOTS OF FACTORS AND
ALSO REASONS FOR GUARDED
OPTIMISM.
IT IS WHY DR. FAUCI AND TRUMP
WORK TOGETHER, THE CONSCIOUS
VOICE AND TRUMP THE GENERATOR OF
HOPE.
UNDERSTANDING PEOPLE CREATE
DEADLINES EVEN IF THOSE
DEADLINES CHANGE.
THE PRESS FORGETS WHEN IT’S BAD
COP/GOOD COP, BOTH COPS WANT THE
SAME OUTCOME.
WHAT WITH THE MEDIA PREFER TRUMP
TO SAY?
IT DOESN’T MATTER AT ALL SINCE
THEY ARE OFTEN WRONG.
BUT A SMART PERSON CAN STAND
BACK AND SEE THE WHOLE FIELD.
THE MEDIA JUST STARES AT ONE
GROUND AND SCREAMS AT THE ANTS.
DANA, YOU KNOW, TRUMP
UNDERSTANDS THAT PEOPLE NEED A
MEASURE OF CERTAINTY AND THE
CERTAINTY COMES IN A DATE.
EVEN THOUGH THE DATE IS GOING TO
CHANGE.
THE IDEA THAT YOU CAN SEE LIGHT
AT THE END OF THE TUNNEL IS A
WAY TO BE OPTIMISTIC AND GET
THROUGH THE NEXT WEEK OR TWO
WEEKS.
SMART PEOPLE UNDERSTAND THIS.
>> Dana: SO PERMISSION TO MAKE
AN ANALOGY?
>> Greg: WHAT?
>> Dana: PERMISSION GRANTED?
>> Greg: I DIDN’T HEAR YOU.
SEAN HAD HIS HANDS IN MY EAR.
SORRY.
>> Dana: SEAN!
MY ANALOGY IS THIS.
IF YOU HAVE EVER WORKED OUT WITH
A TRAINER.
>> Greg: YES.
>> Dana: THAT TELL YOU YOU
WILL DUDE 15 SQUATS, THREE SETS
OF 15.
AND YOU FINISH THAT.
AND THEN THEY SAY COME
ALL RIGHT, ONE MORE SET OF 15,
RIGHT?
WHAT!
YOU -- BUT YOU KNOW WHAT YOU DO
IT BECAUSE IT IS GOOD FOR YOU.
>> Greg: YES.
>> Dana: AND YOU GET THROUGH
IT.
AND SO I SORT OF THINK ABOUT
THIS LIKE, CAN I MAKE IT TO
EASTER?
CAN I MAKE IT TO EASTER?
YES.
I CAN MAKE IT TO EASTER.
IF AT THAT POINT THEY SAY, YOU
KNOW WHAT, YOU HAVE TO DO ONE
MORE WEEK.
>> Greg: YEAH.
>> Dana: OKAY, I CAN DO ONE
MORE WEEK.
IT IS GOOD FOR ME.
AND I THINK, TO YOUR POINT, THIS
WILL BE DONE THOUGHTFULLY.
THERE IS NOTHING RASH GOING ON
EXCEPT FOR MAYBE THROWING
$25 MILLION TO THE KENNEDY
CENTER.
>> Greg: YES, JUAN, IS THIS
FAIR TO SAY THAT LIKE THE
PRESIDENT WOULD CHOOSE AN
ECONOMY OVER THE DEATH OF ITS
CITIZENS?
>> Juan: WELL, I HOPE NOT.
I JUST DON’T THINK WE SHOULD BE
SAYING ABOUT PRESIDENT TRUMP OR
ANYBODY.
WE HAVE TO UNDERSTAND IT, BUT TO
MY MIND, THIS IS WHAT I WAS
TRYING TO SAY YESTERDAY.
THERE IS A DISCONNECT EVEN IF
YOU TRY TO LOOK AT THE PRESIDENT
AS AN OPTIMISTIC CHEERLEADER FOR
ALL OF US.
THERE IS A DISCONNECT WHAT HE IS
SAYING AND WHAT WE ARE HEARING
FROM THE SCIENTISTS AND THE
DOCTORS INCLUDING DR. FAUCI WITH
REGARD TO ONE WEEK OF
REALISTICALLY EXPECT TO LIFT
THIS.
BECAUSE IF WE RUSH THIS, GREG,
AND SAY LET’S GET BACK TO WORK
BY EASTER, THEN WE CAN INCUR A
SECOND WAVE OF THIS KIND OF
CORONAVIRUS OUTBREAK AND GET THE
FAMOUS CURB TO SPIKE AGAIN.
WE DON’T WANT THAT.
THAT IS NOT GOOD FOR THE
ECONOMY, AND IT CERTAINLY ISN’T
GOOD FOR PEOPLE AT HIGH RISK.
GRANDMA, GRANDDAD, EVEN ME.
BUT WE WANT TO BE ALIVE.
>> Greg: I AM BACK TO WORK
COMO JUAN.
>> Juan: THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
BUT TO SAY, TO BLAME THE
PRESIDENT, MR. PRESIDENT, PLEASE
PAY ATTENTION.
THERE IS NOBODY IN THE SOCIETY
WE SHOULD BE WRITING OFF.
BUT EVEN IF YOU ARE JUST
THINKING ABOUT THE ECONOMY, KEEP
IN MIND WHAT THE DOCTORS AND
SCIENTISTS SAY.
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO RELY ON
YOU AS A TRUSTWORTHY SOURCE.
RIGHT NOW, PEOPLE ARE NOT SO
MUCH INTERESTED IN THE KIND OF
CHEERLEADING AS THEY WANT TO
KNOW EXACTLY WHAT WE ARE UP
AGAINST.
BUT WHAT WE ARE BEING REQUIRED
TO DO WOULD HELP.
>> Greg: JESSE, IT DOES SEEM
THEY TRUST PRESIDENT TRUMP ON
THIS.
THE OPTIMISM IS VALUABLE WHEN IT
IS PAIRED TO THE SOBER ANALYSIS
OF THE DR. FAUCI.
THAT IS WHY THEY ARE TOGETHER
GOOD COP/BAD CALL.
>> Jesse: BUT THE POLLS SAY
THE PUBLIC TRUST TRUMP OVER THE
MEDIA.
DON’T MEAN TO RUB IT IN, JUAN.
SOMEONE JUST SENT ME A GREAT
ONE.
ARE YOU READY FOR THIS?
IF YOU TELL PEOPLE THAT YOU HAVE
TO STAY INSIDE FOR SEVEN DAYS
STRAIGHT IN ORDER TO SAVE THE
2020 FOOTBALL SEASON, THE ENTIRE
SOUTH WOULD BE LOCKED IN THEIR
ROOM RIGHT NOW.
[LAUGHTER]
DO IT FOR FOOTBALL.
ALL RIGHT?
THAT IS HOW YOU HAVE TO GET
ACROSS TO THE PEOPLE.
AND I AGREE WITH GREG, IT IS A
FALSE ECONOMY.
LET’S NOT SAY OPEN A BUSINESS IN
ORDER TO PAY WALL STREET
BONUSES.
THAT IS NOT WHAT YOU ARE DOING.
YOU ARE NOT TRYING TO SAY LET’S
KILL GRANDMA SO WALL STREET KEPT
FATS -- FAT CATS.
WE WILL LOOK AT SCIENCE, DATA
AND MODELS, NOT THE MODELS THAT
JUAN LIKES.
BUT THAT WILL DETERMINE IF
EASTER IS THE RIGHT DATE OR IF
WE HAVE TO EXTEND ANOTHER WEEK
LIKE DANA’S TRAINER MIXER.
[LAUGHTER]
THAT DOESN’T MEAN YOU ARE
KILLING PEOPLE TO GET A HIGHER
GDP.
THAT MEANS YOU ARE WORKING
SMART.
YOU WERE WORKING SAFELY BECAUSE
A LOT OF AMERICANS OUTSIDE OF
NEW YORK WILL BE LIKE I CAN TAKE
MY CHANCES WITH THE CORONAVIRUS.
I WILL NOT TAKE MY CHANCES WITH
THE GREAT DEPRESSION, YOU KNOW?
A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT GET THE
CORONAVIRUS DON’T DIE.
THAT IS NOT SAYING IT’S NOT A
THREAT.
IT’S NOT SAYING IT’S NOT A RISK,
BUT PEOPLE SEE WRISTS AND OTHER
MEASURES.
THAT IS WHAT YOU ARE TRYING TO
BALANCE.
>> Greg: TO KATIE, LAST WORD
OF, WHAT THINK?
>> Juan: GREG --
>> Greg: LET ME GET KATIE
RIGHT IN.
>> Juan: GO AHEAD.
>> Katie: WHEN HE STARTS
OPENING UP THE ECONOMY --
INCREMENTALLY AND NOT JUST RIGHT
AWAY, THEY WILL COMPLAIN ABOUT
THE BORDER TO MEXICO NOT BEING
OPENED UP FAST ENOUGH, FOR
EXAMPLE.
THEY WILL SAY THE CHINESE SHOULD
BE ABLE TO FLY BACK AND FORTH
AND THE EUROPEANS SHOULD BE ABLE
TO FLY BACK AND FORTH IF YOU
DON’T OPEN UP THOSE THINGS FAST
ENOUGH.
BUT THE STIMULUS BILL THAT THEY
WERE TRYING TO GET DONE IN D.C.
RIGHT NOW AS WE SPEAK WILL BUY
THEM TIME TO GET THE MEDICAL
EXPERTS MORE TIME TO CONVINCE
THE PUBLIC AND TO ASK THEM IF
THEY HAD BEEN DOING TO FOLLOW
THE GUIDELINES TO GET OUT OF
THIS THING.
AND THEN PRESIDENT TRUMP WILL BE
ABLE TO MAKE ECONOMIC MOVES.
THERE ARE PLACES IN THE COUNTRY
THAT WILL BE LONGER IMPLICATIONS
LIKE NEW YORK, LIKE CALIFORNIA,
BUT THE IDEA THAT DEMOCRATS
DON’T LIKE THIS EITHER BECAUSE
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS SPEAKING TO
THE WORKERS.
THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO BE IN
CHARGE OF, THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO
BE IN CONTROL OF POLITICALLY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS ALWAYS
SPOKEN TO WORKERS.
HE’S ALWAYS HAD A POPULIST
MESSAGE.
THAT IS THE SAME TODAY AND WHY
THEY ARE HAVING A MESSAGE TO
THIS AND WHO IS TALKING TO.
>> Juan: I HOPE HE IS LOOKING
OUT FOR WORKERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES.
BUT I WANT TO MAKE A QUICK POINT
ABOUT THE GREEN NEW DEAL THAT
YOU GUYS KEEP HARPING ON.
YOU KNOW, THERE ARE A LOT OF
PEOPLE GOING BACK TO ’08 WHERE
YOU SELL PEOPLE SAY WE HAVE TO
SAVE AMERICAN EASTERN CULTURE
BECAUSE THERE’S MILLIONS OF JOBS
WITH AMERICAN CULTURE AND
MILLIONS OF JOBS IN RENEWABLE
ENERGY.
>> Jesse: THERE’S A LOT MORE
RESTAURANTS IN HOTELS AND
RESTAURANTS THAN THE KENNEDY
CENTER.
>> Juan:$25 MILLION FOR THE KENN
CENTER?
>> Greg: YOU KNOW WHAT MY SEAT